today we're going to show you the best
seven foods that you need to be eating
to clean out your liver now what many
people don't realize about the liver is
they think it's a storage place for
toxins when
it normally does not store toxins it
gets rid of toxins now toxins are stored
in the fat cells so if you have a fatty
liver chances are you will have toxins
stored in your liver but if you don't
have fat on your liver you're not going
to store toxins now before i get into
the foods i want to jump right into what
the liver does okay so number one it
helps detoxify the body so let's go to
the white board to explain that point
all right check this out we have the
liver and the liver goes through two
different phases actually three phases
but i'm going to focus on these two
phases right here when it gets rid of
poisons or toxins
phase one is all about breaking things
down okay turning poisons
into
a water-soluble harmless particle which
is in the phase two so we've got this
whole chemical reaction there's a lot of
different chemical reactions that occur
not just one so phase one is breaking
things down and then phase two is about
adding things to that uh new molecule
and you need certain nutrients on both
of these sections you have b vitamins
you need antioxidants b12 folate and a
lot of other nutrients so what is the
liver breaking down it's breaking down
plastics pesticides insecticides
herbicides fungicides alcohol caffeine
drugs
aspirin
tylenol
corticosteroids antidepressants high
blood pressure medications
recreational drugs
pollution and and the million chemicals
that come with that
both in the air the water in your food
and then you have people that are
smokers or you get secondhand smoke
benzene and hundreds of other different
chemicals
that's going right through your body
into your liver that the liver is coping
with and trying to get rid of all these
things solvent and glyphosate which is
in gmo food this is like a real big one
for a lot of people so then a kind of
phase three would be the elimination of
this new compound that's now a harmless
particle and it's quite amazing that
your body does this because your body is
able to detoxify naturally which is
really cool now what happens if you get
constipation well everything backs up so
it's very important to not let
constipation go on and on and on do
something about it i have a lot of
videos on that but there's another
condition that's very common
but they're not aware of it and that's
bile sludge there's such a thing as bio
sludge and so you have the gallbladder
and you have all these tubes that kind
of drain into the gallbladder and out
into the small intestine all these
different tubes can get
backed up with kind of a thickened bile
material and so one way to know if you
have that problem is you have
pain or tension or tightness on the
right side up through here
it could be a fullness underneath your
right rib cage in which case you need to
number one take something called tutka
you can look that up as well as follow
the solutions that i'm going to get into
later in this video now a couple other
things that can mess this process up
let's say you're missing b vitamins you
don't have the right
nutrients that can slow things down
or let's say you have a fatty liver that
can decrease the function of the liver
or if the liver is inflamed or if you
have scar tissue as in cirrhosis all
these things can slow down
this process as well as not consuming
some of the foods i'm going to talk
about but the good news about the liver
is that it's one of the only organs that
can regenerate very quickly as long as
you have some liver left like 25 percent
and you change your ways your liver can
grow back into a normal liver so that's
really exciting but there's always a
point of limitation where there's too
much damage that can be done this
explains liver detox all right number
two it actually makes something called
bile bile is uh very similar to like
detergent or soap it helps to extract
certain nutrients and food that are fat
cybel like the fat cyber vitamins
vitamin a d e k 1 k 2 also omega 3 fatty
acids also
there are certain plant nutrients
they're called phytonutrients like
lutein for example that's really good
for the eye
and so a lot of these phytonutrients in
plants are also fat soluble this is why
when you have a salad it's really good
to add olive oil or some other oil to
help extract these nutrients from the
salad but bile has this unique property
to extract these nutrients from your
food and bile is made from your liver
and it's stored in the gallbladder and
as a side note all the extra cholesterol
that your body
makes as well as gets from your diet
is extracted with the help of bile bile
is also involved in helping you
make your thyroid hormones work so when
we go through t4 which is an inactive
hormone to t3 which is the active form
of the thyroid hormone you need bile and
bile also helps us to ensure that
there's no microbes building up in our
small intestine and one last little
point of a bile which is interesting
guess what makes bile cholesterol
cholesterol is the raw material that
helps make bile interesting all right
number three function of the liver
your liver makes certain hormones okay
now you've probably heard of growth
hormone that's made by your pituitary
and that goes down to the liver and then
that activates another hormone that the
liver makes called insulin growth factor
number one igf-1 and you can think of
igf-1 as just basically an extension
of growth hormone so whatever growth
hormone does igf-1 will do so it's going
to help you with fat burning and it's
going to help you make proteins now as
another part of this liver function
related to hormones it helps you
buffer hormones so if there's too much
estrogen in the body or too much
androgens like testosterone
your liver will help to
regulate that also if there's too much
of stress hormone like cortisol the
liver will help you regulate that as
well so whether the liver becomes fatty
or
inflamed
or develops scar tissue as in cirrhosis
all sorts of symptoms can occur and to
help you understand the symptoms let's
go back to my white board all right
these are the symptoms of the liver
itchiness especially in your feet
fatigue or lethargy
belly fat because the liver is filling
up with fat and it's spilling off into
areas around the organs and in the
organs in your abdomen diabetes and
pre-diabetes and insulin resistance
which comes before both of those things
hormonal imbalances especially with
estrogen
testosterone which have all sorts of
cascade issues from
hair loss to menstrual cycle issues to
menopausal problems
many different types of skin problems
occur because of the liver
joint issues like especially arthritis
stiffness
and things related to the gallbladder
like belching burping bloating
gall stones
as well as hypothyroidism because we
need a healthy liver to convert at least
80 percent of the thyroid from t4 the
inactive to t3 the active form of the
thyroid hormone
now there's a couple little last things
i want to mention you have these liver
enzyme tests ast
alt
alp if you ever get your
liver tested and there's problem with
one of these three high liver enzymes
like ast
that means there's damage from toxins
like it could be alcohol medication or
some other toxin
whereas if it's a high alt that's mainly
damaged from just having a fatty liver
and then if it's high alp that could
mean you have a blockage in your bile
duct okay or bile sludge so these are
the main liver symptoms now i do want to
touch on the bad foods for the liver
before the good foods so let me just
quickly go through them the high
fructose corn syrup okay anything with
high amounts of fructose
is really bad for your liver because it
creates all sorts of problems with
insulin it creates a fatty liver okay so
then we have like various poisons for
the liver so poisons is a pretty large
category you have pesticides
insecticides herbicides fungicides you
have heavy metals okay all these things
can be in our food supply but you also
have other poisons like medications yes
medications are also poisons and so a
lot of people develop complications from
their medications that involve damaging
the liver especially things like
prednisone right is it which is a
synthetic cortisol just devastating to
your liver then you have many others
like antacids antibiotics vegetable oils
these are unsaturated oils like corn oil
like soy oil cottonseed canola safflower
and too much sunflower and too much
peanut oil are all high in something
called omega-6 which are inflammatory
especially if they're heated as in fried
foods
you know i see this a lot when you go to
restaurants they have these appetizers
which you eat to stimulate your appetite
like maybe you weren't hungry at all
going to this restaurant you need to
stimulate your appetite get the juices
going and you have things that are
always involving these vegetable oils
like deep-fried onion rings or the
deep-fried cheese or deep-fried pickles
or corn chips then you have things that
are fried in the oil and sweetened like
the deep fried chicken wings that they
have then you have these veggie rolls
which are deep fried and then you dip
them in some type of sugary sauce right
then you have other things with the corn
chips you have all these different dips
all these wonderful appetizers are just
terrible for the liver what's also hard
in the liver is when you have sugar with
protein as in barbecue ribs okay so
that's really hard on the liver
ribs are fine as long as you don't add
the sugary type sauce with them and then
we also have the combination of like
meat and starch right then you have
steak and potato or steak and fries
well you should have this have the steak
and the vegetable but not the starch and
especially not the french fried starch
all these things are really hard on the
liver the more cooked foods that you eat
the more canned foods you eat the harder
it is on the liver as well so that means
the body has to make enzymes and it kind
of depletes the enzyme reserve and so at
least 50 percent of the time you should
be consuming some raw foods like
vegetables things like that and of
course we have alcohol sugar
refined foods like refined carbohydrates
now one point about the liver
if your liver is damaged or fatty okay
and it's swollen
that may refer pain to the right side of
your back a little bit lower
right between the scapula and the spine
it's called the rhomboid muscle and
you'll have tightness
in the back right through here i used to
have that for
many many years i had no idea what it
was and it would go to the chiropractor
and have millions of adjustments and it
never got better well that's because it
was my liver now if the gallbladder
itself is congested not necessarily with
stones but just with sludge
that creates tightness on the right part
of your right trap right through here
that can radiate up to your neck
and you'll a lot of times get that
massage for so many
years without relief
now if the ducts the little bile ducts
between the liver and the gallbladder
are kind of clogged because they're
sludge or stone
that can refer pain anywhere in this
area because it can back up to the liver
as well as some fullness or tightness or
pain
underneath the right rib cage okay so i
just wanted to point that out all right
so what are the foods that are best for
the liver well it would be those foods
that provide detoxification
that provide
lowering inflammation
that helps slow down the scarring
process and the development into
cirrhosis let's start with number one
cruciferous vegetables that would be the
kale the broccoli the arugula the
cabbage the beets the brussels sprouts
and there's many more so cruciferous
vegetables not only have these enzymes
to help this phase one phase two
detoxification process
but they also can trigger your own
body's production of these enzymes to
help the detoxification process plus
they're loaded with nutrients as well as
hundreds of phytonutrients that are
anti-inflammatory that are anti-cancer
that are liver protective that help your
blood sugars so if we take it one step
further and we take cabbage and ferment
it into sauerkraut we have extra
benefits of the probiotics in that
product so that's going to help get rid
of the fat from your liver it's going to
reduce the inflammation on your liver
and the fiber itself can actually feed
the microbes in your colon
to help make more bile which will then
help you thin your bile and allow things
to travel through the liver a lot better
so it doesn't back up but sauerkraut is
awesome for the liver
because it's easy to digest it also is
loaded with vitamin c i mean i think one
cup of like homemade sauerkraut is
almost 700 milligrams of vitamin c
that's higher than anything else out
there what i've been doing recently is
not just having lettuce for my salad
i'll alternate between
cabbage i can cut cabbage or coleslaw
and then other days i'll do arugula so
that will just give me extra benefits
than just having the regular lettuce and
then sometimes i'll do a kale salad okay
kale is like just a powerhouse as far as
phytonutrients and some people steam it
because sometimes it's hard to
chew and digest in a salad what you
might want to try is to take
organic kale raw
put it into the freezer freeze it take
it out
and then it breaks into these little
crystals that you can then put into your
blender
add some blueberries with some water
blend it up and drink your kale salad
number two food is eggs now why are eggs
good for the liver because eggs have the
highest amount of choline
and choline is one of the most powerful
things to strip fat from your liver and
it does a lot of other good things too
but it will also help you regulate
cholesterol but also as far as the
detoxification process
you need a high quality protein and eggs
are at the top of the list to give you
those amino acids
that are necessary for detoxification
but as far as the protein goes
it is the highest quality protein that
you can eat and it's very easy to digest
and it's really easy on the liver
compared to other proteins that are
really hard on the liver the worst
protein that you can eat for the liver
is the soy protein isolates
also whey protein is hard on liver
because these isolates are kind of a
refined protein product and anytime you
eat something out of the normal complex
your body has a hard time with it all
right number three
sprouts
specifically broccoli sprouts but other
sprouts are good too so what's so unique
about the broccoli sprout is it has like
a hundred times the amount of
sulfurophane as adult broccoli and
sulforaphane is one of those
powerful phytonutrients
that is not only cancer protective but
it helps with this phase one phase two
detoxification turning poisons into
harmless particles so if you were to
take just a small amount of sprouts and
put them in your salad or take like a
half a cup of sprouts put them in a
blender with some berries and blend that
down with water you would have something
that is very beneficial for your liver
all right number four
beets beets have special properties that
reduce inflammation in the liver help to
mobilize the bile release from the liver
beets are also good to reduce fat on
your liver even though they're a little
bit sweeter they also can help your
blood sugars so you could eat your beets
raw but it's really hard to chew so i
would steam them and you can add them
with all sorts of recipes and stews put
them on your salad it's it's endless
also as a side note
don't shoot away the beet tops okay
because the beet tops
have the most potassium of anything you
can eat so you want to chop those up put
those in your salad all right number
five garlic garlic is loaded with the
sulfur that your liver needs to make
those compounds in that phase one phase
two detoxification not to mention it's
anti-inflammatory it's antimicrobial so
it does a lot for the liver all right
number six salmon
or other omega-3 fatty acid foods you
can do sardines
you can even do what i like is canned
cob liver okay it's not just cod liver
oil it's called liver it's quite good
but one recipe that i really like in my
salad is to chop up cabbage
and take a can of tuna and mix it with
the cabbage okay so now we have the
omega-3 and the cruciferous together
i'll put some lemon i'll put olive oil
and i'll make a great salad another
recipe that i like is
roasted
brussels sprouts with salmon that's a
really good combination we got the
omega-3 and the cruciferous and number
seven is lemon lemon is not only loaded
with vitamin c if it's
raw not pasteurized but lemon can help
reduce fat on your liver lemon is
anti-inflammatory and it's very sour in
anything sour or bitter is good for the
liver so basically seven foods
you could pretty much mix them all
together and have one meal and that
would be the most awesome meal for your
liver
now there's other things that are good
for the liver as well like apple cider
vinegar of course diluted in water and
drink that great for blood sugars great
for your liver especially for fatty
liver then you have olive oil which
helps you extract fat soluble nutrients
from your
salad and it has anti-inflammatory
properties and you should really use the
extra virgin olive oil in all of your
salads now this is not necessarily a
food it's just an herb but out of all
the herbs okay that are good for the
liver the top plant would be milk
thistle now milk thistle has fascinating
properties related to the liver
it is liver protective
it actually protects the liver from
poisoning and all types of poisoning
poisonous mushrooms
uh poison from a snake
poisons from tylenol alcohol heavy
metals pesticides so if you have
anything wrong with your liver you
should probably be taking milk thistle
as a routine thing especially if you're
on medications because milk thistle can
reduce the complications from medication
now there's some fascinating information
that i did a video on relating to
certain
problems with your foot and how you can
use that to determine the health of your
liver you haven't seen that video you
should really check it out i put it up
right here in the liver playlist